le temps est enfin venu de sortir le
projecteur est de faire un trou dans
l'obscurité
le spectacle en trois actes de ce soir
est prêt à démarrer c'est ça on passera
à chercher les clés mercredi et salua
niasse salut belinda
[ __ ] de merde puissant que cette
soirée ça va être vraiment chiant
ce qu'on fait ça sont vraiment des
malades mentaux
veuillez s'il vous plaît donnez votre
nom laissez donc notre public vous
connaître un peu plus
qu'elle va trôner usb requête
mesdames et messieurs laissez moi vous
présenter notre star de la soirée
ce soir ce sera un spectacle très
violent
voyons ensemble comment faire en sorte
que cela fonctionne
chose la plus importante ici dans ce
spectacle est à voir son autre sous les
projecteurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]